head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
from the New York Post Don lemon's new
show CNN this morning bombs in debut yo
he only he was only able to get 71 000
key demo viewers you know I'm pretty
sure that I mean we get we get 60
percent of that number just in
concurrent viewership on this in fact we
do right now have 43 000 people watching
live and that is key demo viewership for
the most part that means in like 10
minutes we will have more viewers than
Don Lemon got on his Morning Show but
wait there's more CNBC cancels Shep
Smith's evening news program the dude
could have just stayed where he was and
reported the news but he had Trump
derangement syndrome and now he has no
job and then you get this Jake tapper's
rating deficient CNN Primetime show to
end after the midterms so I'm feeling
good how you guys feeling it's fun I
feel like the old guards on its way out
and the new guard is established we I
think we got to open up that uh
expensive bottle of booze here in order
to celebrate this this you know Changing
of the Guard as some people would call
it but you know who would have thought
you know propaganda doesn't pay huh
statism and and just lying to to people
on beheads of the very powerful didn't
work lying didn't work uh what a
surprise sad
I think they just have no audience it's
like Trump was right he basically said
you know CNN is fake news and it's true
like they literally don't have a
constituency at least MSNBC I think
talks to like leftists that's their
audience Fox News talks to like
right-wing people and CNN they're just
like yeah you know we just want to keep
on saying how we hate Trump make all of
our news about Trump and who's our
audience gonna be then the new guy who
takes over says you know we'll make
things independent we're not really
going to be biased anymore well that
didn't happen so I mean these people are
entertaining if you're not doing
politics could be entertaining but
they're not funny maybe you know I'll
see what Chris Licht can pull off with
CNN he's getting rid of these people
Jake Tapper is gone take a look take a
look at this picture CNN this morning
there's Don Lemon all very happy it's
like hey you're doing a Morning Show so
don't wear don't wear a tie anymore like
don't wear a butt nut so it's a jacket
with a t-shirt under it and like that's
that's the vibe it's it's look relatable
look happy it's so cringy pastel pink
got this really nice turquoise there's
no amount of money CNN could offer
any serious person to go and try and do
something with them I'm sorry I would go
it could totally change everything at
CNN if they asked me to do a hit Prime
Time show a hit Prime Time show I would
take I wouldn't take myself seriously
that's the problem with these peoples
they're afraid of looking like fools and
it's okay to look like a fool the
audience agrees I would I would go
outside and get a steaming pile of trash
and then just do a live stream of that
and that would probably get more views
than what they're getting right now
no but frail though it would if CNN
right now announced they were replacing
Tapper with a steaming pile of trash it
would get like 5 million views on its
debut night no joke the next day it
would get about a million and then it
would consistently hit about a million
from people who are like how long is
this going to go on for them just
showing steaming trash well you get
different angles of cameras with they
can zoom way in so you can see the
bacteria growing in real time and then
it's really you know entertaining dude I
would I would turn that on I would watch
it if in fact if Cena announced that I'd
be concerned they would pull our viewers
away I'd be like oh man you know because
people going to want to watch that if
they like dumped Gatorade on Don lemon's
head when he wasn't expecting it it
would get 100 million views yeah he
slimed on Lemon you let it go ahead of
time we're gonna slime you at some point
today oh dude I I I I okay so I'm
assuming the reason didn't fire Don
Lemon is because he's under contract if
I was if I was Chris licked and I was
taking over CNN and I I couldn't fire
him I'd be like your show is going to be
great You're Gonna Go on stage and the
audience are all going to have
buzzers
and when at least 10 people in the
audience press the button you get slimed
so there's 30 people in the audience
that means you better say the right
thing otherwise the audience is going to
send you to slime town maybe they gotta
let Don slime himself wait no one likes
to be slimed against their will so don
you just take it upon yourself at some
point tonight I'm slamming myself he's
gonna be called slime lemon slime I got
an idea I got an idea so you know how we
do a chicken City that if people give a
hundred thousand super chats it
accumulates and then the chicken party
happens you could do something like that
where Don lemon's sitting at a desk with
a soccer horn right next to his head and
he's just sweating as he reads the news
and people are sending in money to the
show and every hundred dollars it goes
just right in his face and I gotta
they'd make bangs yeah I don't want to
objectify Donnie though
I feel like it would just be like a way
to roast them and they people would love
to see them like really well dressed
like you know like man cured in the
morning just totally slimed I think
people would really enjoy that right I
would listen listen if CNN is failing
and every everyone hates these people
that's where the money's at baby yeah
you got to be like hey look the audience
hates you guys and you're under contract
let's make money off it yeah what can we
do how about there's a a big cartoon
hand with a glove and it loads pies and
every you know 500 it launches a pie at
the at the host what's the what's the
game where you get dunked in the water
they're sitting they're sitting in this
like a little adult yeah they're they're
sitting on the dunk tank reporting the
news and every time they get something
wrong they get dunked into the water
what about factually incorrect I like I
like pies I like
um sliming them big fan of slime I feel
like the only person who'd play these
fun games is Trump he's the only one who
doesn't take himself too seriously and
would be willing to actually throw
himself out there like do you remember
when he was riding in that car at that
big race car thing and everyone was like
screaming they were just cheering for
him I don't know like he knows how to
get the crowd going I feel like he'd be
able to like make really good TV make
good ratings these people they're just
like sticks like they just don't want to
step even a second outside of their
comfort zone and I also think like
people who are content creators make
YouTube videos they would see like oh
this is a video Someone really liked let
me do that again let me do the same
thing or let me try something new but
these people are corporate media so they
are not interested in trying new things
they just want people to accept what
they are putting out at one point he
said maybe a black could it have been a
black hole that swallowed the plane and
I he'd have been goofing around maybe he
was just letting his psycho his
psychosis run but I mean it didn't do
well it didn't play well for the for the
network him saying that which is too bad
because we need that goofiness I think I
remember when Trump was at a rally and
he was like these lights they make me
look orange they make me orange and
everyone's laughing and he's like he's
self-aware yeah you get a roast the the
swimmer the man like passing the woman
and he's like oh she has like a wind
burn because he just like swims past her
so quick it's like he just comes up with
like the best comments it's not fun
this Shep Smith you know on CNBC Don
Lemon it's not fun and this and you can
see it in the in the videos they were
trying to make it fun and it's not look
at this the three of them sitting there
looking at Hillary Clinton on the big
screen is just nightmarishly cringe it's
just like dude let go at least have a
hologram of Hillary there in the room
like Fox something high-tech I think Fox
did that right remember when Fox did the
chef smith thing were they the giant
tablets
that was so cringe as well oh yeah yeah
they had giant tablets and they were all
excited like the future of The Newsroom
is gigantic screens that you can like
use your hands and I'm like I'm pretty
sure that's not the future of The
Newsroom dude but you know whatever man
what do you think's gonna CNN's gonna
turn into
is it like QVC they're gonna be selling
and chucking and jiving like the latest
beauty products and and jewelry be like
I could see Don Lemon doing that that
could be a very I mean they got to make
money somehow what does it CNN does that
mean what does it mean Cable News
Network news Well Cable's done so they
don't read that name anymore well I mean
there's still a lot of money in cable uh
because people still do use it and now
what we're seeing with these uh
streaming services they're creating
bundles that are basically the same
thing as cable was but now it's just
online so I think the cable industry is
not going to go any I think what they're
going to do is they're going to convert
into online streaming providers but CNN
plus such a failure
for CNN plus had to say um I did how
much did they spend but you know I think
like they're gonna hold on till the end
because they're like oh we're still kind
of riding on our coattails from when
like people liked this kind of thing but
I think if they try to transition to CNN
plus type content it's like people
already made it known that they don't
want that content you would have to get
someone to Rebrand the network work like
someone totally like someone like Tim or
something like someone completely
knew that's like independent new fun
willing to say whatever I mean and I
mean whatever but I guess the problem is
that they're funded by
military industrial you know I I gotta I
gotta imagine that that's a fair point
see the thing is I don't trust CNN I
imagine that they'll they'll say
something like look we're trying to do
right and we want to you know be more
relatable why don't you come and fix it
if you take them up on that offer then a
day later they're like here's why war is
good read it and you're gonna be like
but I don't want to read it and they're
going to be like read it you know
otherwise they're gonna lock you in a
room and put you in golden handcuffs and
or threaten like if you say that it
violates your contract some abstract
thing they'll have like a 70 page
contract that they want you to sign
before you start oh I've seen them
they're ridiculous huge contracts
they're like not 70 but it's like you
know maybe I mean close to it actually
with like vague terminology like
anything that we make morality Clauses
where it's like if you say if you offend
someone's delicate sensibilities they
can terminate your contract and it's
just ridiculous it's like that they
bought who discovery bought CNN is that
right the IPA I think the discovery owns
yeah it's like buying VHS in like 1997.
like now I own the VCR VHS or betamax
like what are you gonna do with VHS now
it's a dead brand it doesn't the age of
the video cassette tape is is now done
the age of like stodgy news reporters
pretending to tell you the truth they
tried with Casey neistat that was CNN
right CNN hired Casey and I said and
then he made beam or whatever or he
turned beam into CNN or something and it
didn't work I guess I don't know they
did it and they were getting views or
whatever but then they just stopped
maybe they were doing a lot of paid
promotion that wasn't paying off I feel
like they're never going to be fun or
entertaining so that's off the table but
I think if they did real journalism then
people would really appreciate it
obviously I realize that's completely
far-fetched not gonna happen but they're
supposed to like you know like question
presidential candidates and debates and
they're supposed to do serious things
it's like they're not like the Real
Housewives of New York or something like
they're supposed to do some serious work
although that would be pretty funny but
I I just think journalism is lost and
they're choosing not to be journalists
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday Friday at 8pm
and become a member over at timcast.com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time